Joe Rogan isn't who you thought he was I
assumed that he was this kind of like
far right kind of alt-right dude based
on simply what I had heard about him
especially after he said people say like
oh you know you're a secret conservative
like you could suck my and I'm a
bleeding heart liberal when it comes to
a lot of [__] there it is I just also
believe in discipline and hard work
turns out that Joe Rogan has some mostly
Progressive views on Health Care on
universal basic income which is like
giving money to people for free abortion
gay marriage and most notably
recreational weed but what's confusing
about Joe Rogan is that he doesn't fit
into the full box of a good liberal he
has people on his show that like are
kind of radioactive in our culture and
this is one reason why he's so popular
in a world of black and white polarized
narratives Joe Rogan kind of breaks that
for better and worse there's a lot to
critique about Joe Rogan but there's
also some stuff to admire as well I did
it all in this deep dive video we made
over on YouTube